after a red carpet strasburg session and
wikis hand back to Brussels to a busy
week a budget for relocating migrants
ear rules on travel packages mass
surveillance of EU citizens labeling of
organic products and how to prevent a
radicalization of young Europeans MEP s
will be hitting the ground running
welcome to the agenda harboring 160,000
asylum seekers tax money on monday emmy
piece will vote on the allocation of 400
million euros to take the relocation
plan work when it comes to citizens
privacy there's a before Edward Snowden
and an actor Edward Snowden the man who
made shocking revelations about US
government spying on European citizens
on Tuesday I matey's will vote on a
resolution which mentions new cases and
addresses how European institutions are
dealing with the problem good news for
travellers big or small on Tuesday
travel packages but online will have the
same protection as those button shafts
travelers will be able to cancel have
the same protection if something goes
wrong and get better information on what
they are actually paying for also on
Tuesday any piece will vote on what can
be labeled organic food the aim is to
better protect and inform consumers and
on EU producers will also have to comply
with these new rules on Thursday MEP s
will announce this year's sakharov prize
finalists a lot of sweat tears and
sometimes even blood for this human
rights advocates of aamir then
when Francois Hollande and angular
Merkel address the Parliament in
Strasbourg and it is asked for a union B
to choose to the 21st century like
everything else it takes money on
Tuesday MVP's will vote the 2016 EU
budget how to prevent radicalization and
recruitment of European citizens by
terrorist organizations on Tuesday
enemies will host a public hearing on
the subject they tuned for a fully
towards week take care